- So, The Carters just
released their joint album,
Everything is Love,
completely unannounced,
and with it, came a brand new music video.
- This time, they rented out
The Louvre, which, how Sway?
The Louvre and its international art
serve as the foundation for a ton
of themes in this music video.
Here are some of the symbols
that you might have missed.
- While Beyonce is known for having
high energy performances
throughout her videos,
in Apeshit, most of her movements
are actually pretty subdued.
The Carters are purposely statuesque,
barely moving, in front of one of the most
recognizable portraits of
all time, the Mona Lisa.
The Carters are literally living art,
and the three faces in the frame
are portrayed as legendary equals.
The two live up to this
particular comparison.
Art history grad student, Heidi Herrera,
noted that people around the world flock
to both the Mona Lisa and the Carters,
just for something as
simple as a quick picture.
Vulture points out that
throughout the video,
the duo continues to make classical
art come to life in brand new contexts.
Like Beyonce dancing as
Nike, the Greek goddess
of victory for you know, obvious reasons,
or when she reigned with her fellow female
dancers in front of The
Coronation of Napoleon.
The painting depicts
Napoleon crowning his wife,
Josephine, the first
empress of the French.
She switches to a nude
wardrobe and lioness hair
to dance in front of The
Great Sphinx of Tanis,
and pulls her hair back to
wine in front of Venus de Milo.
One of the most important
artistic references
was when Jay-Z did his verse
in front of The Raft of Medusa.
The painting shows the
aftermath of a French tragedy,
where a naval boat crashed
due to poor navigation,
leading to a number of deaths.
Out of the 150 plus crew members,
17 decided to stay, and 15 survived.
The moment captured in the painting
was when the crew members
saw the rescue ship,
after 13 days with little to no food.
This hope, after the turmoil,
and the determination
to stay, symbolizes
where Beyonce and Jay-Z
are in their relationship right now.
They went through hell,
but they persevered.
- Now, let's get into the cultural
significance of the video.
There's one overarching theme,
and that's black excellence.
First, let's talk about the
portrait of Madame Recamier.
The woman depicted in the painting
was the wife of a banker
and a huge socialite.
Putting black women in front of this piece
signifies how black women
themselves are iconic.
The styling of the women
is also significant.
It's reminiscent of French artist,
Marie Benoit's Portrait of a Black Woman.
This kind of depiction of a black woman
was rare for its time
period, and historians
believed it was painted in
support of abolitionism.
Keep in mind that The Louvre houses
a lot of art from the Napoleonic era.
Of course, we know Napoleon as one of the
most prominent colonizers in history.
It's no accident that Jay and Bey position
themselves as art, in the
midst of these colonial relics.
They've literally colonized The Louvre,
to celebrate who and what they are.
This painting here, depicts a woman
caressing a man with a stab wound,
and it's imitated in the video
by this black man and woman.
The stab wound is representative
of police brutality against blacks,
which brings us to the image of black men
kneeling outside of the museum,
a reference to Colin Kaepernick's protest.
Black women swoop and sway
among the white marble floors
as Beyonce sings, "I
can't believe we made it."
It's a celebration of success
in the face of oppression,
and these images of black bodies in this
historically white space emphasize that.
- Did you see anything
we might have missed?
Let us know in the comments below.
- And subscribe to Insider
for more video breakdowns.